based on the best-selling novel from the  world renowned author Lewis ja swordsman  is a compelling and unforgettable  martial arts MMORPG experience with over  80 million players and numerous  prestigious gaming Awards in China  swordsman takes players on an epic fully  voiced cinematic journey of tragedy and  redemption with groundbreaking visuals  and riveting action-packed compact as a  disciple of one of the 10 legendary  martial arts schools you'll embark on  your journey to become a martial arts  master each school offers unique weapons  skill trees custom combos and fighting  styles  combat in swordsman is tactical  responsive fluid and is highly  customizable  this is the MMO that fans of martial  arts kung fu movies and Wu Xie have  dreamt up with real-time weather ragdoll  physics and motion capture animation  from master martial artists swordsman is  a beautiful captivating and enthralling  world unlike any other